[Music]
everybody to the h3 podcast we were
formerly known as the h3 experience but
I have to say after meditating this
weekend I believe we are now the h3
trans sensual experience we have gone
beyond the experience we have
transcended time and space
welcome to the correct opinion zone this
is the Tuesday episode where we talk
about current events and basically
everything you're going to hear here is
the correct opinion you need another one
of those this is no longer an experience
my did it worked in I guess we miss you
have to hit it one more time turn it off
guys today's episode is sponsored by
honey and I want to plead you all guys
please everyone who watches on YouTube
head on over to iTunes Spotify Google
podcast play whatever the heck they're
doing and subscribe to us there so you
can get us in your car in your commute
wherever the heck you are where you
don't get access to videos listen to us
on the podcasting app let's get those
numbers up because we are transcending
the genre and the experience itself so
slam those subscribe buttons I do you
boy a solid this Friday we've got Tim
Heidecker coming up what excited about
that so don't miss that yeah last night
yeah we were on kill Tony
kill Tony is the number one they love
saying yeah and it's true number one
live podcast live world but it's live in
front of a live audience yeah and they
do it every Monday night at the Comedy
Store they tour a lot too right but they
were gracious enough to have us on the
show and it was a blast those guys are
awesome I can't wait to have them in
here live kill Tony check it out we were
on there there their show but obviously
don't click away because we're just
getting started
most importantly we need to talk about
Papa John yeah let's let us Papa John is
having a meltdown
Papa John spent a little too much time
like I'm saying I like my pizza a little
you know overcooked but this pizzas this
beats is a little too overcooked yeah
you know check this out
so Papa John as you guys all know
they're late great Papa John who was
outed from Papa John there's a whole
there's like a whole kind of paradoxical
situation going on Papa John Papa John
is trying to kick Papa John out but how
can Papa John be Papa John without Papa
John so Papa John the company right is
trying to kick out Papa John the person
the Shatner but they are for the John
just change your name at that point your
Papa John the pizza you can't separate
the pizza from the man so they're trying
to distance themselves from here as much
as they removed his face from the
branding that was right that's what was
the final straw for Papa himself yeah
he's like you cannot take my face off
that pie box no because basically my
face looks like a pizza pie I've spent
so much time near a pizza oven and it's
a basically preview of what's gonna be
like when you open it but they're
they're saying we can't be dependent on
one person especially this person yeah
so he made this is I love this story
this is just so he made a website Papa
himself called st. papajohns.com I am
Papa John like a Spartacus you know that
I am Papa John he he acts like it's a
social movement where like everyone
[ __ ] cares so much about Papa John I
am Papa John we you shall not silence us
we are we are legion we are pizza so let
me read you some of the excerpts you
know how long do I feel their website
when you order beats how you can choose
the toppings and then it like Falls like
olives oh yeah all fine if it was here
still on this website you can still
order pieces for my save Papa John's
calm here you guys let me read this is
the the
his homepage so let me read an excerpt
here for you all here I built Papa
John's from the ground up and remain its
largest shareholder I love my company
its employees its franchisees its
customers they don't love you anymore
the board wants to silence me this is my
website and my way to talk to you
save Papa John's calm as I said in a
recent letter I miss you all very much
how the [ __ ] you could claim the mitt
your just your pizza CEO I miss you guys
all you fat butter loving sauced
gluttonous sons of [ __ ]
I love sometimes I'm at home and I
imagine sucking the butter garlic sauce
off your fingers I miss you all very
much more than words can express
sometimes sometimes garlic sometimes I
rub garlic sauce and use it as a
lubricant it reminds me of how much I
love you better times
Papa John's is our life's work and we
will all get through this together
somehow someway I can only imagine how
difficult this entire situation is on
you know he goes from I to we I filled
Papa John's and then he's like is our
life's work wait we will all get through
this
well imagine Papa John saying to just
some [ __ ] guy who orders pizza from
there at once a week I can only imagine
how difficult this entire situation is
on you I feel like you wrote this to you
right I think it wrote it to himself I'm
very sorry
that you all have to go through this
just know that I still finger my wife
with butter garlic sauce
Bowie's listening anything and Beau
don't even get me started about beau
that kidding right
I can only imagine how hard this has
been on beau we pack his lunch with
butter garlic sauce every day this is
this part is real know that in every
minute of every day you are in my
thoughts and my prayers who exactly
you're looking Rama clean dude occluded
in this website are links to recent
press releases news articles and recipes
to my world-famous garlic sauce which
also doubles as a really good sex
lubricant to remind you of the better
times
signed sincerely papa
butter garlic song Shatner Oh Elsa ro we
are getting the truth out there garlic
my Bart my butter garlic sauce was
invented as I tried to make my own sex
lubricant my wife tasted it accidentally
and said hey pretty good I was emotional
beautiful journey a roller coaster and
except for the sex stuff that is all
written you see that was very Germanic
Papa I mean I don't know in his mind he
really sees this as a big pizza war and
people are picking sides there he has a
lot of support I mean there's people
demonstrating outside the White House
right now free papa
in his mind Papa John and Papa John Papa
John's exist without Papa John know just
like when the Civil War happened a
country divided cannot stand as the
Abraham Lincoln famously said and I feel
that Papa John is kind of a pizza civil
rights leader in his own right called
award this is a hot war this is a hot
oven war a cheesy hot oven war about oh
this is just his life story he's
actually got all the legal papers
because he's suing Papa John it's like
dude y'all started a war with a [ __ ]
make sure he could finish it
he's got feed some money anyway I just
loved his little cover letter so pop I
wish you all the best in your fight
there's a standing invitation for Papa
to complete his case on our show we had
previously reached out and better times
and I have to say Papa passed yeah he
said I got Peyton Manning throwing
pizzas into the American living rooms of
everywhere now all the sudden who would
you have left Papa who D have left me
that's who it's time to come
on this show bring the butter garlic
sauce cuz we're gonna have a good
old-fashioned reach-around soggy pizza
anyone know what that is soggy it's a
soggy pizza when a pizza got saggy or is
this like a metaphor there's something
else
Papa knows um Alex Jones is in the news
again but this time you may not expect
why this or this story just cracked me
up I had to talk about this alright now
Alex Jones you know and love him guys
I'm sorry I think our stream just got
pulled down why I'm just I felt for them
I look so stupid I was gonna make a joke
like that Dan you guys need to
coordinate the jokes here no well he
gave me well I am I am somewhat hesitant
to mention the boogey man named Alex
Jones hey Jay what's going a so he you
know mr. mr Turner frogs yeh was doing a
advertisement during his show recently
let me show you the video that he was
watching and and tell me if you catch
something in this video because it's
free its brief but the this internet
soup supersleuths did find it so watch
closely now
heard about it from family and then from
George Noory and others that I had to
get involved Infowars yes so far cement
in force yes calm to go look all of that
up did you catch it no how does he talk
that guy they talk if you later on over
fo yeah he's all dad advertising
nutrition when his voice sorry it's the
Alex Jones voice [ __ ] my throat Apple
was he doing an ad for skin
hmm I love it he's so funny man he puts
on so many hats like he'll advertise
anything and all of a sudden he's doing
Infowars yes it's like a Martha Stewart
Brand info worse yes
get your skincare products over here at
well anyway so well the family and then
from George Noory and others that I had
to get involved Infowars yes there's no
space on that in force - dot-com to go
look all of it looks like flesh so he's
showing all of his open tabs brows phone
no [ __ ]
yep so the internet super sleuth went to
work crunching the numbers Turing the
frogs gay and what came up will shock
you know here it is the title of the
video in question was naughty tea babe
Marisa minx relieved of [ __ ] hunger by
stuff can I open I can I show this let
me see if I can show an image of this
you know I can't show the more you know
the thing but it's basically I mean
really all you need is that title let me
read that for you again if I can not ET
babe stands for trans it's a girl penis
for those who are not initiated she's
not et babe Marissa minx relieved of
[ __ ] hunger by stud that's how that is
of an event is Stan - with the sentence
better really what do you want me to
break down not ET babe she's a naughty
girl with a big old dick presumably okay
she and then her name is Marissa minks
and she has such she has an insatiable
[ __ ] hunger you look she is so thirsty
for coffee she's so hungry she's
relieved she's fine she has insatiable
hunger for [ __ ] but yet did but what's
this done I feel like I know it said I
want to make sure that is the guy that
[ __ ] okay I think it goes back to a
horse it's like a horse no but it's like
that guy's off
[ __ ] stud so this girl with this
insatiable hunger for cop has finally
after all of her searching on the earth
for this one stud that could relieve her
thirst for [ __ ] she was relieved of [ __ ]
hunger hmm
by stud so that's pretty interesting and
I'm not one to judge you know watch
whatever you want but it is Alex Jones
and he did have a video title not ET
babe Merc me relieved relieved of [ __ ]
hunger hmm I love the Alex Jones was
watching that he hasn't addressed it by
the way oh
I mean how what'd he say yes she was
relieved of her [ __ ] hunger to be fair
he may he may have addressed it but I
hunted really hard and this is such
outstanding news that if you if you
google anything related to this all
you're gonna find his articles about you
know was insatiable tea babe the
interesting thing about Alex Jones
watching a trans porn is that heat one
of his strikes that he got before the
closure of his channel was for he called
trans people mentally ill that's nice
he's like you may be mentally ill but
I'm I mean that doesn't mean I can't
beat off to it does that make him
mentally ill if he likes it I guess it
does I can't leave you what I said
couldn't make him I just love this is so
funny so funny man mmm so relieved of
[ __ ] hunger next time you see Alex Jones
just remember that by stud nice little
story great little story wish we had
Alex Jones to call him you tell us about
mm-hmm 90 day fiancé
love the show we've talked about a lot
about this show not a 90 day fiancé
yeah and fisa and George the gold digger
yeah so in this story this this show is
just a gold mine yeah
90-day fiance eats well I thought this
show was like an old show but it's oh
man I mean it may have been around for I
don't know how long it's been around
just looks like it's from their night
days yeah yeah but it's still going III
got a set DVR to record this show
because it seems like gotta be one of
the more entertaining shows on TV so
this lady has married I believe in
African and she is in Africa visiting
the family now the family one of their
native dishes is snails and she's very
hesitant to eat the snails which makes
sense to me yeah be respectful in the
face of your fiance's family and you eat
the snails and you enjoy them right okay
she's you know she doesn't seem to be so
on has a problem eating food so she
doesn't seem necessarily that she should
have a problem putting it down but got a
little nice like tomato sauce in there a
little creamy okay native dish it's very
quiet is a quiet food energies I'm uh
I'm boosting it as much as possible
this is cellphone quality the if she
takes a little but I'm okay with it she
ripped half off and it's in her mouth
and she's saying kiss me my her fiance
kissed me and get it out of my mouth Oh
gross they're watching by the way you're
not slipping up so what are you they saw
that yeah so she basically said to her
fiance kiss me and let me spit it into
your mouth so that I don't have to chew
it anymore
that's not paying respect to anyone I
mean that's horrifying thing to witness
just spit it out on your plate and say
Amen name for me hey come here pretend
to kiss me I'll spit in your mouth
nobody will know they're all look
they're all the cameras airing right you
know it there's like three cameras
watching hey let's get let's get another
one of that a let's get a slow-mo if we
can point to five no I don't know no how
are you are we yeah man let's see let's
get it close look kiss me
she's like damn I only don't she's like
I only [ __ ] with butter garlic sauce say
Papa say Papa John calm won't this white
American
mmm this takes on a whole new vibe
I hear toaster comes into the past that
a romantic kiss if I've ever seen one
sucks it right out of her mouth and he
[ __ ] chews it to that goddamn MVP
that guy just saved the day
thank you Michael he's like man the
things I do for a green card mm-hmm
these relationships on these shows are
really all about getting a green card I
don't think any of these relations are
very genuine so it's really what's so
interesting about this show is like what
is this one person it's like we wanting
to thank right it's like one eligible
dateable person matched up with one
completely undoubtable person and then
you kind of just see how much that one
dateable person can endure for a green
card and I think that guy in this moment
reached his limit he did it no yeah he
did it damn very special stuff guys my
shows on fire today
are you saying that you wouldn't suck a
snail out of Elah smell I sucked I'd
suck garlic butter sauce out of your
mouth that I think I have in fact Ella
you know you you sure did you know that
I
this shows on fire today we are killing
it all I'm saying is that next time you
order Papa John pizza's say Papa John
calm try replacing yeah your sex lube
with butter garlic sauce and see if that
doesn't get you somewhere new nice this
is one in viewer advice and I read it on
safe Papa John calm it's under tabs of
tech of techniques and strategies
nearing my [ __ ] hmm that's what we
all came for here a lot of debate over
last week about wiping techniques about
how best to approach the [ __ ] help us
to clean it help us to manicure it I
received an email from somebody
said they near their [ __ ] and that a
change of their life for the better I
was so intrigued because it was so
insane so preposterous of an idea that I
thought I had to try it out
ela says why do I keeps me messy you're
getting message from strangers on
discord I wrote that to Dan but yet well
now I'm intrigued and you're getting
bombed by strangers on discord I just
keep saying all kinds of notifications
on my ela I'm talking about nearing my
[ __ ] campus so I was trying to
distract myself from the and said what
the [ __ ] they found you who found it I
don't know these are just like we're
just in a private channel it just does I
don't know okay
who's Raz hmm sneaking in no no our
private discards guy infiltrated but we
are talking about nearing my [ __ ] so
if everyone could please focus on what's
okay sorry sir
so anyway I was about I was gonna near
my [ __ ] because it just seems so
insane I was like forth the sake of the
show list of it yeah but the other side
of me was like this is kind of a really
weird and same thing to do and you could
burn your skin yeah and the [ __ ] was
pretty sensitive right mm-hmm apparently
what I understand but then I don't also
I had a feeling that this guy was [ __ ]
with me you know he seemed genuine but I
can see someone be like I'm gonna get
Ethernet near his [ __ ] knowing full
well that would ruin my life so another
great fan emailed me and was like dude
do not near your ass and here is why and
he sent me this Craigslist story that
was so funny I had to read it to you
guys I had to share it with you guys so
for now this story alone put my nearing
my [ __ ] on hold on hold I'm still
open to it frankly we got the product at
home yeah I have the prot three I don't
know why Amazon they made me buy three
bottles almost like I'm this [ __ ]
weird guy just like have an apocalypse
stash of nearing my [ __ ] look the
world may be ending but my [ __ ] is
going to be
you clean one of them was called balls
bum oh yeah I wanted to stay in my
pursuit of the sensitive NER that
wouldn't burn my [ __ ]
I found a product called balls bomb
that's made for applying to your balls
balls ball cuz I gotta buy some balls
ball so I don't know I've got balls bomb
yeah and I was thinking of just getting
it just seeing what happens but you guys
you guys read this and tell me I don't
know
this dispute me most most definitely and
it rings so true let me zoom in on this
so this was from Craigslist it's called
warning don't shave that hair I've
recently made a mistake in my life and I
offer my store to you that you may learn
from my heir it all started as many
things do with me having trouble
[ __ ] did you write this no dan I
think we need some kind of music I want
to play can you play sad violin no I was
not constipated this was not a
regularity problem but a matter of
technique
it seems my ass hair had grown to such a
length that my tiny grow Grogan's we're
constantly getting tied up and the
matted jungle between my ass cheeks it
led so much frustration with me knowing
that I still had something to drop but
not able to shake the the tenacious turd
loose from its butt hair dwelling
eventually would have to do two things
either reach down with some paper and
try to pinch off the lingering loaf
which required careful precision to
avoid smearing the creature all over my
rear especially since I had no way of
seeing what I was doing or just go for
broke start wiping and hope that I could
remove all the leftover fecal matter
before the toilet reached it's can't be
flushed threshold
I was contemplating this problem this is
very long yeah can you cut today like a
paraphrase here let me paraphrase so
yada yada yada he did the deed now I
have great respect for anal hair like
everything in this world God created it
has it's all my purpose in existence it
was only after I had removed it that I
started to learn how much I had been
taking it for granted for one it
provides friction I learned that this
next day when I walked out into the Sun
headed for class after climbing two
flights of stairs and starting to sweat
I started to notice something unpleasant
the sweat was accumulating in my crack
and was causing the unpleasant sensation
of my two ass cheeks sliding past each
other with every step I thought about
going to the bathroom and starting to
wipe it off but I had to go to class I
thought eventually it would dry
unfortunately it did dry but only after
mingling with the microscopic [ __ ]
molecules lingering around my brown
starfish yes when I stood up after class
my axe Chiefs were stuck together in a
slimy stinky [ __ ] sweat combination as I
made my way back to the dorm it started
to itch God did it itch I felt like a
swarm of ants was making its way up and
down my craft fighting to keep from
jamming my hand down there and
scratching away I rushed back to the
dorm unfortunately again this excretion
caused me to sweat and when I when I
finally reach my room my cheeks were
sliding back and forth against each
other like a pair of horny cane toads I
quickly dropped my pants and attempted
to drop my ass by sticking it in front
of a fan and spreading my cheeks as I
pulled the two mounds of flesh apart a
horrible stench burst free and filled
the room every dog within four blocks
started to hell I had the worst of it as
the ripe aroma a festering [ __ ] and
sweat went into the fan and blew my face
I got to keep from heaving as I sat
there fighting vomit in my mask you
spread dripping with the concentrated
aroma of my body odor mixed with the
tangy smell of my own [ __ ] blowing right
into my face I only had one thought
I will be like this until my hair grows
back for weeks later on trying to deal
as best I could
wiping my ass at every opportunity I
discovered another wonderful use for
this ass hair ventilation I attempted to
launch a fart only to get it stuck
between my ass cheeks apparently with no
hair the two pink twins can get
vacuum-sealed together and the result
was a frustrating fart that slid up and
down between my cheeks like a lost
gerbil as if there wasn't enough I am
now in during further torture as anyone
who has ever shaved anything knows when
hair is growing it becomes stubble I
imagine your ass having the texture of a
brillo pad well that is what I'm dealing
with now is a hellish torture and there
are times when I just look out the
window and contemplate why I shouldn't
just jump out and get it all over with
rather than endure this agony friends do
not shave your ass here Wow
but see see I think thank you thank you
for that anecdote but what I think about
is um I loved the part Moyer was almost
vomiting yeah I definitely get that like
but he shaved okay I'm nearing Denari is
like shaving button so I would the
stubble I won't deal with the stubble
well it will grow back so basically once
you're near your [ __ ] you're stuck in
a vicious cycle because once that
stubble grows in and your I can only
imagine your [ __ ] issuing with every
step you're back in there nearing you're
stuck in the net you're stuck in a loop
yeah I'm gonna be doomed to a hairless
[ __ ] forever I don't have to like
take two weeks off not to mention that
you couldn't burn yourself all right I
keep telling you because I saw him what
everybody was so entertaining to be like
okay guys i naired my [ __ ] I feel
like but then I also don't want to be
the guy that neared his [ __ ] you know
hmm what if I ball bombs my [ __ ] it's
the same thing I do fear of the [ __ ] and
sweat emotion the potential vomit God
wouldn't be so great to hear you talk
about the smell of my [ __ ] and swimming
yeah because you'll be there I'll not be
there I'll be out he was gonna
yeah I did was doing it for you man I
was not asking for this well I'm still
intrigued but the guy definitely spooked
me straight I do want to tell you that
the poll that you did on Twitter oh yeah
there has been an update with the
numbers so um let's open the poll
actually so I was so interested in this
debate we've been having with with from
the front or from the back mm-hmm
because again as I said there's two
worlds of wipers and they don't even
know that it they exist and I felt like
an outcast my whole life for lifting up
my balls and reaching under there mm-hmm
and so I said I go to h3 podcast on
Twitter at the HTTP podcast and I asked
our loyal fans how do you wipe your ass
from the front or from the back and it
may surprise you but we have a lot of a
lot of results here first of all
sixty-six thousand five hundred and
thirty-four people participated so thank
you I feel like this is an actual
legitimate census of the American public
like this is for men only because women
only have one option they're supposed to
wipe away from the badge and I do love
the top comment here
I don't think man wipe Amanda said well
I don't know who the [ __ ] she's been
with but she's had a foul she's had some
foul relationships maybe she dated that
guy we were just reading really every
time I've been with a guy just smells
like ass and sweat so last time it was
60 for you now it's 61 39 mm I feel like
it's being brigaded by the front wipers
but anyway 39% wiped from the front
those are like-minded brethren who lift
their balls improve and you know perform
a scoop from the front it's really a
scoop the way it is it's a scoop
it's just eject scoop and the skilled
scoop is a scoop that I've been
developing for a long time you lift the
balls you scoop you're clean baby you
scoop the [ __ ] out this is a smear I
don't know this
you can't come here but 61% wipe
it's a traditional wipe maybe but I like
scoot you just want to scoop out when
you're dealing with them whole you want
to be scooping out you can't wipe a
whole you scoop out of a whole am i
right
31% from 39% of you know exactly what
I'm talking 61% of you wiped from the
back and that's pretty I don't have to
say I'm kind of surprised by how many of
them are out there like me that wipe
from the front I mean that's pretty I
mean that's really close to 50% that's a
that's a 10 percent variance we're
talking about so speak up front wipers
don't leave me in the trenches scooping
grenades out of my ass okay help me
represent the world that we are out
there we are strong we are people we
have rights we are Pappajohn and go to
save Papa John dr. Nam and use butter
garlic
I've heard that butter garlic sauce is
so powerful it actually can act like
Nair and burn the hair right up again
I'm gonna try butter garlic sauce in my
[ __ ] tonight that works so I thought
that was an interesting scientific
experiment we should do more polls
because I feel like we're actually
making an important contribution to
science here good we are really I feel
like we're doing important things here
this is way more than an experience we
have transcendent experience
this is the h3 podcast fully and light
moment of science and clarity we'll be
right back after this break with Logan
Paul verse ksi stay tuned
okay do you like free money yeah cuz
that oh thank you EULA wasn't expecting
a response now that I know you like free
money would you like to hear about honey
because that's what it does
honey is an extension for your browser
that browses the web's the whole
internet for the perfect coupon for
whatever you're shopping for oh oh I'm
on Amazon trying to buy dog food oh
honey
boom coupon whoa just save me money like
an old man clipping coupons by the
fireplace every evening for you for free
honey that should be their slogan an old
man clipping coupons for you as you
browse don't believe me the link in the
description join honeycomb slash h3 has
saved people collectively over a hundred
and two thousand dollars in the past
couple of months that's an average
saving of twenty five dollars per person
whoo you also may be thinking that honey
doesn't work at sites that I shot that
well the truth is honey works on over
30,000 sites including Amazon eBay new
egg raiser Walmart and more so much more
pretty much I mean everywhere that I've
shopped honey's like I love I love using
it on Amazon it even shows you like the
price history of a product and if it's
like the lowest now or not the big
question is how is honey free what's the
cash there's no catch
your dips honey gets a small commission
from sites every time they clip a coupon
for you so it's always free there's no
catch it's easy to install takes a
couple of clicks and then you're gonna
be off to the races saving cash give it
a shot it's free and it literally takes
ten seconds to install so use the link
in the description join honey dot-com /
h3 try it out it takes two clicks and
two seconds I guarantee you're gonna
love it
and you're gonna say dang get Ethan
thank you for join honey calm / h3
you
welcome back everybody I'm out of breath
from running to the bathroom Neela's not
back yet did we were we had a screen or
was the comeback slick and perfect yeah
we did have to go to the screen for
about five seconds yeah I had just gone
to the screen as you open the door we
went to a screen here you Dan come on
quiet okay
damn we're gonna we're gonna get out of
this office this office wearing is so
[ __ ] small
you got a run to the bathroom we're
looking for a new office five second
slate screen oh my god we just got we
just got demoted to experience oh we
were transcendent but we just I just got
knocked back down from enlightenment
back to the experience damn dude harsh
okay well let's get right on to the main
story Logan Paul first ksi everybody is
talking about Logan Pulver's ksi the
boxing match you look yeah who do you
think won how do you know what happened
could you think one um I thought case I
won it was a tie okay
suspicious all right I'll show you guys
I'll show you guys let's go over some
stats okay I find this stuff really
interesting before I kind of talked into
it look I'm Paul risque aside the boxing
match you guys have all heard of it I
kind of got to give credit to these guys
cuz even if you hate them both it's just
irresistible it's irresistible you gotta
talk about it you gotta love it I mean
really and and it was pretty slick I
have to honestly have to give them
credit they they masterminded this crazy
thing they sold out this arena they had
eight there how many 800,000
pay-per-view viewers that's right
[ __ ] I got it I gotta give him it up man
up off it was definitely pretty exciting
like on the day off everyone was talking
about it pretty cool definitely some
great NEMA Bowl moments in there that
I've let me share with you guys but on
the whole I just want to say I'm not
gonna sit there and hate okay I want to
say I gotta give these guys some credit
words do yeah definitely taking this
whole online YouTube experience to to a
new level
yeah so general admission tickets
started at IIIi want to bake this down
because they've got always said this
fight is bigger than Mayweather verse
McGregor and I've heard a lot of people
say that I'm gonna send that because
that is such a ridiculous statement I've
heard them say and I've heard other
people reporting on it being like I
heard um I've heard it in really
reputable places of being like they had
more views than their press conference
had more views more hype so I do want to
break it down I want to compare I want
you know ones you know show what it
what's going on here
I mean Logan Pulver's ksi that's you
can't really get more hype online than
that mm-hmm it's like max hype I mean
what what - could you pit together
that's better than that
shoenice for Joey salads would you guys
watch you nuts first Joey salads I would
I would be scared to put shoenice in a
robe anyway pretty niche audience I
think yeah somehow I don't see that
point eight hundred thousand interviews
did she shoenice would [ __ ] eat his
opponent I want to see that I mean don't
the only real option to get more than
them would be something like PewDiePie
PewDiePie again it's like Ryan's toys
reviews the [ __ ] out of a
twelve-year-old oh yeah watch that so
here's here's some stats for you guys
okay general admission tickets started
at $39 with the high
price going to 600 averages probably
like 50 bucks they sold out the arena
right dan I think they sold out what
they were offering I think the arena
actually sits 20,000 and they only have
15,000 available for some okay so they
sold 15,000 live attendee take why
smiling you are you laughing looking at
our notes oh we've got funny notes oh
just our notes are funny heads up people
we skipped a funny story we did what are
we skip but we could get back to it
later and a couple of oh well hang on
this is so related to everything we were
talking about but now it's confusing
yeah we'll get to it later oh man this
young couple was using Nair mmm-hmm on
their [ __ ] ksi so they sold 50,000
live attendees they took in about two
million dollars at the box office that's
okay I mean Who am I
that's great that's amazing okay 800,000
YouTube streams
that's incredible that is incredible it
was $10 per pay-per-view mm-hmm so
that's about 10 million bucks and
revenue and what would you write here oh
oh keep in mind 1 million plus oh yeah
over a million people were watching
illegally on Twitch mm-hmm which is
pretty funny I saw a picture of twitch
staff was in the illegal tip room like
Portsmouth staff for watching they made
this press release like we were trying
as hard as we could to remove so that is
crazy revenue but you got also
remembered that was probably such crazy
costs in the same cost to putting it
together and say let me put it this way
we were considering doing a show at the
Ace Theatre which we never did but the
cost of paying the venue alone was like
close to 50% of the tape yeah and this
was a crazy event huge yeah I was kind
of like really profession ten million
dollars may sound like a
but considering how many people were
involved and and I mean Logan Paul and
ki are super rich
so getting two million dollars for a
single payday sounds good but the scope
of what it was I was like hmm that's it
doesn't seem like that much money when
you think about Mayweather and McGregor
like Mayweather got paid like three
hundred million dollars alone right Dan
was it three hundred million yeah that's
what I I don't think there's actually uh
I'll hear official figure about it it's
speculated three hundred so Mayweather
made three hundred million in McGregor
Gate made a hundred mil I was like how
the [ __ ] was that big of a difference of
money it's huge
I was like what that's so much more well
that was really so I if I had to guess I
don't know if they had sponsors so I
guess that ksi and Logan Paul each made
like I don't even know that they each
made 5 million I don't think there was
that much money involved no no way
because the Logan Park could be a I mean
they definitely made a good and they're
fine they're fine they made they made
enough money to buy a house with cash
but it was Dave made something cool man
gotta give it up so here I wanna
probably took them so much time to
organize the whole thing well the
training it's not really a maze work
it's like no lines no it's insane the
training the promotion they were like
this whole narrative they were sewing I
mean well I think the peripheral hype
was really beneficial for them to like
all their videos and everything we're
getting like way more views than usual
so it's like it's kind of this
next-level vlogging we are creating like
this crazy like drama real drama I mean
it was extremely orchestrated these guys
are best friends they're [ __ ] loving
it they're straight-up butter garlic
sauce on each other reaching around
double a [ __ ] right now straight-up
satisfying their insatiable [ __ ] hunger
fine if they're what nerd oh yeah bro
you know that ksi Nair his [ __ ] and
Logan Paul ate that ass clean boy
insatiable insatiable hunger that is the
best state I love the title
what was it telling that
what was the title of that video because
I feel like I can't forget it dang bud
let me scroll up you guys we're gonna
we're gonna rewind here relieved of [ __ ]
hunger so they were relieved of their
[ __ ] hunger for each other it's like
when you're teaching language we're like
teaching you how to use this sentence I
feel like that that's that phrase has
got a live in infamy I'm relieved of
[ __ ] hunger so I think like not only was
it about their payday from this single
fight but everything around it was so
hyped and so big that it was greatly to
the benefit are you being did we say
what word actual results for people who
don't know I mean yeah I'm getting there
so Mayweather versus Matt Gregor just
for comparison 4.4 million pay-per-view
buyers that's insane I mean that is
insane especially when you consider that
the purchase price of that was a hundred
dollars that equals 440 million we are
in Vegas doing it it was insane
everybody was glued to like the whole
Vegas wasn't about the fight actually
was really weird we were playing
blackjack in the Hard Rock and we and
and it was a really weird thing with
only certain hotels had the license to
play it ya know you can just buy it I
found that so weird we thought you
couldn't we could go play and watch it
on all the t's and I found out no so
then
Austin's bodyguard had his brother he
had his cellphone on the living room
table live streaming on Instagram on
Instagram his TV and so we were watching
a live stream of Instagram of a
recording of a TV and that in random
life she ended up having like 10,000
viewers by the time yeah and then we
found out that was a whole thing like
there were thousands of people doing
that yeah it's kind of hard thing to
take it out but like there was a huge
crowd behind us to just to watch on this
little I don't because you couldn't find
it anywhere well anyway that's 440
million Wow
and I just I looked it up again that for
point
or million that's just domestic that's
just us people
mmm so overseas it's probably another
million so that since the live tickets
generated 55 million what the [ __ ] were
they charging people I think ringside
tickets were probably thousands of
dollars like tens of thousand probably
whoa total estimate they brought in 600
million do that is close to a billion
dollars from one fight crazy
so Mayweather as we say got 300 million
McGregor paid 100 million I was just
really curious because I was like why I
mean like four point four verse 800 is a
big difference but I mean having a
million live viewers is pretty
significant but I guess that's him
ten dollars makes a big difference well
anyway just a little comparison there
they were very far from from the most
popular but again to their credit that's
a huge event we're talking about like
the biggest live event of all time yeah
so I just thought was interesting to
compare those two events now let's talk
about the fight itself shall we
Jake Paul won in the fifth round out of
six via a technical knockout they ended
it but you know what even though Jake
Paul did win it seems that the most
entertaining and talked about moment of
the night was this image of Jake Paul
with the bloody nose so shout out to
call me short gamer he was amazed and
confused like that's gonna be a lot of
people's Twitter profiles unlike a lot
of avatars well I don't I don't want to
take too much pride in a guy he's fine
by the way year one yeah he's one he's
fine it's just pretty pretty great I
guess I don't know so that we that was
the highlight of the night which it
doesn't say much here's a video of Jake
Paul being punched in the face 40 times
they've been super strict on the
copyright stuff so I guess this one is
editorial enough so here you go how many
times was Jake Paul punched in the face
people really hate to
Paul they're like yes right lots of
people love them too
those are kids it wasn't then just
telling us that he just is now at
Lincoln million I gotta say he's more
likable Logan I agree I mean he when he
was a guest on her on our show he was
III he came out looking much better and
I think everyone had a sense of
appreciation for him you know that said
let's watch that being said let us watch
him get punched in the face definitely
landing some solid punches vegies
definitely Landis installed punches my
good now as I've heard it is Jake Paul
was significantly larger taller taller
was not really a fair matchup bye-bye
apparently Jake Paul was forced to
slouch down because at the height
difference and the size difference was
so great but hey shout out to a dead you
for getting 40 slamming good solid
punches to the de [ __ ] dome not bad
not bad it was some guy should I say
good good thank you - thank you - dank
againin take a good this was pretty
funny - honestly post-fight interview
with Jake this just shows you this
rivalry I always said and suspect that
Jake and Logan actually hate each other
deep deep hatred of this kind of proves
like here's Jake's big moment by the way
since when - Jake he's got a kid they
call them little Jake Paul
doesn't have a kid right what No so here
he's doing his post-fight interview and
his love and belonging is enjoying his
victory and his brother that's what the
[ __ ] I want to know what did you what do
you win the boxing match you get a kid
that kid's gonna be such a piece of [ __ ]
when it grows up I just googled it I
guess this is a meme there's a whole
bunch of little Jake Paul or mini Jake
Paul they call him but who is he kidding
kidnapped I guess there's a bunch of
pictures of it yeah this kid looks like
me
I'll take him I'm sure they're related
but when did you [ __ ] out a child
doesn't know it's his kid you know what
this kid is he's like um he's like from
these Greek mythological stories where
it's like your firstborn is foretold to
/ surpass you and subscribers and Jake
tries to like prevent it from happening
but the kid ends up bigger and then he
also [ __ ] Jake's wife his mom just like
the Greek mythology I'm trying to make
it interesting
No Oedipus anyone to own not connecting
too old for this audience let's move on
so anyway he's enjoying the limelight
he's having a lot of fun Logan Paul
comes in and steals the steals the
Thunder and it's a blast to watch listen
joy what do you think that kid's gonna
be doing in 18 years you know there's a
very cute kid and nobody knows it
couldn't be anything yeah you could be
anything you could be the president
right it could be an astronaut he's
gonna be great
he's gonna be raised really well by a
bunch of well-adjusted people their dad
for a good role model I mean mm-hmm
guy is a superstar and tonight you made
a star of yourself as well you're
wearing that WBC amateur strap it was a
hard yeah because like you watch the
interviewer he's trying to care about
Jake he's really trying to care about
Jake he's really wants to care about him
Logan you don't care about what Jake
saying but watch Logan in the back he
acknowledges that there's an interview
see that he looks back like three times
did you see that let me go back so you
can everyone acknowledge that and so in
that moment he goes you know what I'm
gonna [ __ ] and this interview like you
can see the gears moving in his head
watch this he looks back all these not
on me look back so many times okay now
watch what happens now much much respect
to him each and every one of you in this
room who's not paying attention to me
please turn the cameras towards me and
all interviews and all conversations
that an RR about me and please everybody
focus
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
he's telling Michael you know you're
right Jake is so much more adorable
yeah and in that interview he was being
very gracious and victory and everything
and just you know if you see the I don't
know if we're gonna watch the Logan one
but Logan's like I [ __ ] won yeah this
is [ __ ] yeah we're not gonna watch
it yeah wait we need to gift that look
of Logan doing a triple check you did a
triple check and he shut down the
interview so great that moment is just
beautiful that was captain
[Applause]
I don't know what this is by Jakes new
worst Oh shop or in BO I don't know what
this is but uh does that make it okay
my merch what I mean is merch my merch
I'm Logan Paul merch to someone say
merch and Matt be maverick calm that's
about all you need to see from that and
that was great but I'm telling you that
brotherly rivalry is thick as yeah there
is something butter garlic sauce let me
tell you that sauce is thick as it gets
okay
delicious creamy mmm insatiable hunger
relieved of insatiable butter sauce
hunger anyway this shit's [ __ ] gold I
love it
what else we got okay well guys listen
we've talked about Jake and Logan Paul
and ksi and Deji and we've talked about
it all hats off to them but the fact of
the matter is that the real fight is the
one that we're all waiting for Frank
invasion versus Ethan Bradberry now if
now there is a prelude to this oh I
didn't say it was a tie by the way
the fight was a tie between Logan and k9
which for if you don't know is extremely
rare one of the rarest outcomes for a
boxing match
ister almost unheard of so a lot of
people are saying that how come was
rigged to help hype up their second
match and to that I say do you really
think they would do that and the answer
is yes absolutely not
well that is an interesting claim
because as far as I could tell that
would be a pretty serious crime to fix a
large sporting event like this but again
you know yeah would they do this yes
definitely yes I personally found that
outcome pretty disappointing I would
have been more excited if
somebody won cuz then there's an
underdog story going into the next fight
but then that kind of makes it more real
cuz they also want like the better story
well I think they thought that I was the
better story you think so yeah maybe
does that mean that all the bookies won
like what kind of [ __ ] is that
like everyone how many people bet on a
tie the book is it like sorry hmm pretty
shady I agree it's pretty shady are
people gonna be just as hyped for the
second fight I actually don't think so
because in in there first of all it's a
tie
I think everyone's disappointed by that
it's frankly I think everyone's kind of
over it and then the Logan and case I
both made videos being like it was a
great fight I respect them so much and
this whole facade of being like I'm
gonna eat your children or whatever hmm
that's the Mike Tyson classic like
coming your children praise be to Allah
Mike Tyson nobody can [ __ ] sell a
fight like Mike Tyson you once said to
an opponent I'm gonna eat your children
praise be to Allah I mean [ __ ] I don't
know I'm better yourself fighting than
that serve Activision I don't think that
the second one's gonna be as hype
because I think the you know I think the
illusion is busted that they hate each
other but anyway I'll be there I'm gonna
be there and I'll tell you what i want
to send Joey salads on a live report I
want him to livestream it
we have a salute anyway yeah he's mmm I
think he's gonna do me so anyway so on
that that same day prank invasion tweets
at me
me neither were in Santa Cruz enjoying
ourselves in a great vacation and this
honestly just made it even better for me
I had a blast with this he goes I by the
way for full disclosure I was on the
phone with Frank invasion not on the
phone but I was tweeting with him in DMS
and I was like hey do you want to do I
know your meme we'd all love to to talk
to you and do a segment with you because
I mean you've been a consistent part of
the show for so long and we caught him
he's becoming starting to become
self-aware
I feel like with his recent kissing
pranks and then he and then we agreed
that we would do it and he ghost it out
on us which is fine but then a couple
days later he tweets this at me I
challenge h3h3 productions to a fight if
I lose I delete my YouTube channel and
give him a hundred thousand dollars well
first of all Chris if you delete your
YouTube channel what the [ __ ] am I going
to talk about I'm gonna throw the fight
on purpose man we can't lose that Jim
come on that's history man but so I
proposed to him how about a quick game
for a quick kiss instead which is you
know something I've been proposing to
him for a long time yeah I want him to
come in here now I gave your approval to
him what he got my number is that can I
get your number I was like [ __ ] you got
any butter garlic sauce I have a I have
a insatiable thirst for [ __ ] thank you
for getting with the exact phrases so
anyway this turned into a whole thing
Ken bone stuck up for me god bless ken
bone he said I volunteer to serve as
tribute in your place my Papa bless my
efforts in the battle to come
Ken bone was prank invasion I thought
that would be interesting but he said
and in prank invasion not to be outdone
tweeted how about you ask ela client
about my kissing prowess she'll tell you
all about all you need to know now quit
deflecting are you gonna fight me or run
scared bro you look like you disappeared
for a year and you were in prison and
you've been lifting weights that whole
time like the last video you may I was
scared I was like this guy was in prison
for a year like you look jacked bro you
look Patrice Wilson jacked do you think
I'm insane do you think that's my skill
that would get in a ring with you and
fight you why don't you fight Patrice
wilson dude I mean he his veins were
like surging
like what did you do to be in prison for
the past two years to be that jacked
because he disappeared - I always love
when we get into this kind of fuse or
whatever the word is they always try -
yeah I know they could stab at me
because you're married I'm gonna go for
your wife yeah did it work
no well Eli I'm asking you now as you
directed me what about Chris's prank
kissing prowess what about it hmm quit
deflecting are you gonna fight me a run
scared you [ __ ] dumbass you're gonna
fight me like everybody like if you
challenge me to a fight on Twitter I am
duty I'm like honorbound
sir I challenge you to a duel
no bro I actually [ __ ] work I
actually do [ __ ] every day I'm not
training in prison to [ __ ] kill
someone and then he continues all these
youtubers afraid to take me on in the
ring mm-hmm look at that face and then
of course is he changed his profile
description - I am the best kisser in
the world another step into the being
the me also where
yeah the meme the main verse kind of
looked too self-aware at that point so
what I was really hoping for now that
prank evasion has kind of entered this
world of boxing
I would love so much to put together the
first ever h3 podcast h3 transcendence
experience special Fight Night and I
will put up $100,000 $100,000 to the
winner of prank invasion verse I don't
know who you guys think is the best
matchup Joey salads
shoenice Ethan Bradberry maybe we can do
a poll on our HP podcast handle but we
will organize event and put up a hundred
thousand freakin dollars to the winner I
will referee it okay I will be there we
will judge it it's gonna be incredible
night prank invasion put your money
where your mouth is I'm putting up
$100,000 for you to fight Joey salads I
wonder what people think we should do a
poll or something yeah we should
definitely do a poll but that would be a
frickin blast man I have to do this you
have to so that's what I was thinking
what do you guys think does that sound
like a fun time or what just gonna be
like a fight
McDonald's hmm Dan yeah throw up a poll
let's get a live count on it um no I
want to rent a venue I want to publicize
you don't want to be a big deal not a
big deal just like an episode it's like
an episode of the podcast hopefully I
get sponsors to help me pay those mm-hmm
pay the prize dude
the winner gets a kiss from Chris maybe
we can get that Pappajohn sponsorship
that I've always been looking after do
you want to talk about this Chinese
people story before we move on to the
shoenice story and what come move onto
show nice I love this story I guess
maybe we can talk about it next week so
good apparently a Chinese company a
Chinese couple apparently sex education
is so poor in China that a couple was
trying to conceive for four years and
they were having anal sex the whole time
I don't know that's possible so they
were trying to conceive and then it
wasn't working and they went to see a
doctor and the lady said every time they
have sex it's usually painful so she was
like let me examine you're like why is
it painful for four years and then it's
a great purchase it turns out they
mistakenly have been having anal
intercourse Lou gave the couple a sex
education handbook and one thin months
the woman became pregnant
to show their appreciation they sent the
doctor a live hand and 100 eggs as a
gift you know you think of humans as
these really smart evolved creatures but
when you go out to like the rural rural
parts of the world without medicine or
doctors or technology available we're
[ __ ] each other's in the ass trying
to make ourselves pregnant huh that's
interesting yeah right the guy's just
like yeah that's how it let's say you
get pregnant that blows my mind that two
human beings can flaps anal sex trying
to get pregnant like when you're that
disconnected from technology that that's
how that can go down I'm Bradley that is
pretty rare to be so lacking of
knowledge but it's not uncommon and like
sexual education and there is not really
something enough yet yeah the big
takeaway that was interesting for me is
that in Ch rural China apparently sex
education is so oh I can't vote on it
that's disappointing
I opened the threat the poll just just
show me the damn results okay minute
break
apparently sex education and China is so
poor that people are out there having
you know shooting loads and each other's
butt holes mm-hmm trying to [ __ ] out
baby literally so now is this story so
anyway okay got that out the way great
let's move up a little
shoenice is a [ __ ] lunatic in other
news we mentioned shoenice so briefly in
our last episode so briefly in fact I
want to show you the video so you can
see how brief it was just so that you
can understand the reaction he had how
insane it is okay
shoenice did you know she's nice oh he's
a legend he eats cases alcohol so he may
I've heard of him actually
hey ASMR eating chips video you just
never showed it by the way
thank so that was you know very light
mentioned and we went into the comment
section um a boy strap up because this
is a wild [ __ ] ride my dudes
so apparently shoenice has like 20
different accounts and he switches
between them I don't know if he thinks
that we don't know that it's him because
they all have his name in the title or
maybe he switched into other accountants
to upvote himself but this is a wild
ride
shoenice first comments thank ya bro for
another mention wish I could be the
hundredth podcast I'll behave love you
guys and then he replies to himself
thank you he didn't log out of the right
one then he logs into shoenice youtube
thank you thank you
then shoenice youtube videos let's do
this shoenice inspirational quote of the
day you nice loves ela and wishes she
would forgive him if you guys don't know
he had called you a Jewish [ __ ] or
something sort yeah something sweet like
that and then boo nice ghost hyung ding
was sure nice let's do this which is the
same comment left by shoenice YouTube
videos instead shoenice believe it
exclamation I believe Ethan is willing
to forgive
shoenice bah ha ha ha yeehaw wish Ethan
would pin this he continues shoenice
deleted videos to see shoenice would be
legendary
the real shoenice deleted videos wish
upon a star bro wish wish upon a star
bro shoenice is not dead shoenice
the mental sad man never duplicated give
this a thumbs up everyone
shoenice exposed i will come to cali bro
let me know this are you [ __ ] how I
was taken to do cos like are you mind
blown yet did he create all those
channels you think every comment or you
you think he already had I think he
already had them shoenice is well known
for having multiple channels and
constantly erasing videos and using
other accounts as I was saying he had a
ASMR video channel for a moment so not
surprised that he has all these accounts
I am shocked and awed frankly the scope
of this operation and I will continue
just for the sake of posterity
shoenice revival she nice is in revival
mode asha next winning channel shoenice
has always win it shoenice to lidded vid
x9 said yep continue on a few nice is
nice shoe nice is nice actually
shoenice impersonation and parodies mind
over matter hmm not sure what's the
relevance of that one like that should
have been from the show nice
inspirational quotes right you got a
mixed up should not get your [ __ ]
together man got to keep your identities
organized
shoenice redemption redemption time
shoenice deleted videos let's do this
shoenice deleted videos x28 top comment
YouTube Hall of Shame - Bert cool
shoenice would be legend interview
shoenice classic videos ela can make me
eat whatever she wants or surprise me
with love East
what anyway beef oh okay right will be
we're almost done here guys so bear with
us isn't work shoenice storm chasing
a podcast storm is brewing shoenice
loves LA beast we shoenice trailer-trash
jokes oh yeah shoenice deleted videos x6
mind over matter I feel like he's giving
himself a crap talk because he's on like
xx account
shoenice war hero deleted videos anyone
notion Isis a war veteran like ela
shoenice impersonations yup shoenice
free shoutouts thank you shoenice back
the original back to finally close it up
without thank you for replying
dude that was so [ __ ] nothing you
know what's even crazier when I saw that
I was like you know what if we're
talking about wack pack Howard Stern
wack pack that we want to build up our
own shoe nice is like thee yeah
Beetlejuice and so we were trying every
I've tweeted at him I emailed him and
this [ __ ] psycho that spent five
hours replying 100 times I can't get
ahold of him I have no way of getting
all of them
so shoenice I've said your name three
times and have to spin in a circle shoo
now shoo now shoo not have summoned the
spirit of Shanae come back into the
comments give us a way to contact you I
want you to be part of this show
shoenice I think you have what it takes
to be the first official member of the
ht3 goof gang gang gang is pretty good
how bad all right we're out here on the
fly people hey a little update this poll
is neck-and-neck
it's like going back and forth Ethan
Bradberry and Joey salads both hovering
around 42% Joey was ahead a little bit
but now Ethan let me ask you this who do
you think would put up the best fight
because let me tell you guys Chris from
prank invasion went away for some kind
of sexual crime and he is jacked so who
would give up the best fight Ethan Ethan
has a madness he's got the fighting
spirit for sure but I think Joey I think
Joey what would you say is winning right
now neck and neck it really is go ahead
and not kidding it keeps going back it's
actually tied right now nobody cares
about shoenice right he's down at 16
because I think shoenice would actually
and I'm not saying this as a joke I'm
saying literally would kill him I think
that he would die if she died in the
ring Joey salads or Ethan Bradberry who
would offer a better fight are you
texting during our show you I just voted
okay who'd you vote for
I can't say cuz that's true that's good
I want to keep it anonymous
you have a preference because I'm asking
you well I you don't want to say it I
honestly can't say which one I prefer I
think they're both great candidates but
also you got a vote to see the results
so I think Joey might be a little taller
and a little heavier hmm so I think that
he might offer the best challenge too
right now it's at Ethan Bradberry 42%
really Joey
now it's 43 oh good Ike I think Joey
salads would be a better candidate and I
think Joey salad is more up for anything
so Shuna I'm calling out shoenice first
I just want to contact you yeah Joey
salads and prank invasion if you're
watching this the gauntlet has been
tossed for the h3 trance ensel
transcends transcends Oh boss and in
translation thank you
I am calling out Joey salads prank
invasion beat them bradbury all three of
them in the ring together a free-for-all
Rumble
let us transcend together thank you look
it's official some times on the show
we've got a couple more things to cover
here folks we've got this story just
makes me rock hard they pull this up I
don't know this is too graphic this
photo actually on the main page
probably not you want to look at the
ceiling to the article do you want to
look peek at this and tell me if you
think it's too graphic I think it's fine
I saw it really a little tush maybe not
I don't want to show it you're this one
I could show I'll show this I just won't
move it so I don't know if that helps
you at all not really
first North American sex doll brothel
opens in Toronto actually here you can
click on that picture this it long I got
this so what does that mean a brothel
instead of having human sex dolls that's
some bad
instead of having humans you can have
sex with they have sex dolls realistic
sex dolls we have a photo of the dolls
don't we did yeah where are they the
dolls I've got it you gotta go so if
you're wondering what I'm talking about
here is some of the choices our doll so
you have a choice of Anna
it was busty as you can plainly see huge
very busty romantic and spontaneous I
don't not sure how a doll is spontaneous
but I mean I think a doll is pretty much
the opposite of spontaneous if that's
possible about as predictable as it gets
Erika who's young mmm gorgeous and sweet
you've got Harper the perfect girl next
door you've got Jasmine exotic faced
angel that just means she's black exotic
faced angel okay guys
scarlet the absolute American Dream yes
nothing more American than butter garlic
so are we in Papa John's tonight or what
nope and Yuki submissive I think all
dolls are by definition submissive they
literally cannot help but be submissive
innocent not when I'm done with her
and Rose a fault this is some wild Jake
you guys that we're talking about here
so you choose to do what all you want to
[ __ ] with now their rate and membership
then crack me up okay wait if I see it I
was like you could probably look a real
prostitute for this price so for half an
hour you get one doll for 80 bucks and
two dolls what do you need two dolls
they're not living
imagine taking the both their lifeless
heads and like how much is it to buy
your own doll I think those real ones
actually are like thousands mm yeah do
you really need a real one at that point
it's like Ian said he when he was
researching at 4000m hmm researching it
Ian I didn't ask you hmm wasn't part of
our research kudos I love that you can
have a threesome with these things man
180 no discount
that's just double the price I know how
I could double the prices up discount
you can get them for a half hour one two
three or four hours they have a grand
opening not even like a $10 off nothing
but I'm saying man give me a discount
grand opening 25% off the price now guys
you can use your imagination and
understand that [ __ ] the same fake
doll as many men before you gets a
little strange I guess it's true of
women but their biological creatures
they shower they walk around you know
yeah all know that fake vaginas got to
get blasted out after like a thousand
times right but I guess you get the
mileage out of it after that I mean dude
the human body is regenerative has a
very beautiful ability of rejuvenating
itself and healing itself but this is
not a battle ax is gonna get blasted out
after probably a hundred times so I
guess that's how Isis
sweet innocent Yuki is gonna get blasted
out okay anyway yeah I guess they they
calculate that based on the mileage they
expect to get right now here's a great
little twist on this the the
prostitution Association is fighting
back because they're afraid this is
gonna cut into their market I wonder how
much it is for a real prostitute I'd
like to see their rip their rate card
it's probably more $80 for half an hour
Ian do you have an information on that
are you asking specifically I think 80
would be quite cheap I think that would
be like a [ __ ] or something I don't
think that would be the full monty right
so you save a couple bucks and you [ __ ]
a doll that a bunch of dudes dicks have
been in I wonder if they have insatiable
hunger for [ __ ] so that the people who
own the dolls said the doll like a girl
will be ready and waiting in your room
we do encourage the use of condoms just
because we don't want people to well
there's still a chance of getting a
sexual disease can you like you like
that gave a [ __ ] a lifeless doll not a
condom these days you just sanitize the
gauges clean it man I am NOT when they
don't want their responsibility you've
seen that room I jerked off in for the
sperm test imagine imagine it's that and
then you [ __ ] this doll that other guys
all bunch of dudes have had their way
with and then so the prostitution
Association the association of sex
professionals strikes back they said
quote the sex affection of a person
cannot be provided by a doll you would
say that they are different and
compatible services they do not
communicate they do not listen to you or
caress you they do not come for you or
look at you they do not give you their
opinion or drink I didn't ask for your
opinion
sorry they do not give you their opinion
or drink a glass of champagne with you
champagne alright sorry
whoa I didn't ask for I didn't
- um they do not give thank you Dan
they do not give you their opinion or
drink a glass of champagne with you one
of the members also said it's another
strategy of the patriarchy that presents
us as objects without rights or souls a
privilege of the wealthy class that's
funny because in a way isn't it better
for a woman more accessible like to let
men do whatever they want with an object
instead of a person well I think that
their perspective is that it's female
empowerment and that you you're not
telling a woman what she can or cannot
do with their body because like
prostitution is outlawed a lot of places
and there's a lot of women that we do
want to make their living that way and
they say hey don't tell me what to do
with my body
that's right that's true but to throw
these sweet innocent submissive dolls
under the bus is just low the low blow
they also added do you realize that
you're [ __ ] a doll where did they add
it and that's really gross and you have
to use a condom with that anyway cause
you get some dudes jizz on your dick
that was their best counterpoint I was
like that's interesting they had a video
showing how they build all those dolls
and it looked like a graphic westward it
was basically a direct parody of West
world except not allowing hits in the
[ __ ] vagina in that like you guys all
watch West world it's like this really
epic building of a clone except than
this it's like like titties get bolted
on and ass comes up and like some guys
dangling with like labia on a fake
vagina is like okay damn turkey neck the
West world songs playing hi shadart
shredder would [ __ ] the hell out of a
doggy sex doll he's so horny all the
time and sometimes we take shredder the
dog park and he he's a little Romeo man
he [ __ ] and we have to we have to strap
him up because he just [ __ ] everyone
at every
oh he's eating give you let me give you
guys a plate better
good boy shredder eat some eat some food
I'll take it a dog park - [ __ ] well
small update real quick we're up to
three thousand votes on the poll and
Joey is pulling ahead
Oh interesting is that 45% - Ethan
Bradberry is 40 so Dan can you reach out
now that you said that I feel like I can
reveal my vote was it was it was Ethan
Bradberry what's yours to learn - that
just cuz I so crazy
he has the wild eyes what are you
talking about wacky wacky man Rumble
[ __ ] the rules like a free-for-all I
think that's what we got to do we can't
try to blow up like a serious event now
I would love to see a four-man rumble
would be all that a few nights he would
[ __ ] kill them all he'd be so psycho
so anyway Dan get a hold can you get a
hold of them Joey Ethan and prank
invasion and see if any of them are
actually interested 100 thousand bucks
I'm putting the prize up very generous
of you see what you're right I pray that
we can get sponsors because that's a lot
of [ __ ] cheddar cheese mm-hmm if we
fool God there's some sponsors out
there's a lot in fact they'll do it for
5,000 I change the price 5,000 I feel
like the price could be negotiable
there's got to be some sterile more but
the shares and the follows so tell him
there's some minute for them
we just haven't decided yet no I just
got some we get all hairs and got him
how long you been going cuz I have a
couple more stories you get two hour and
a half okay let's bless their John
McCain an American Hero what better to
follow up our story on [ __ ] dolls
laughs it open two for the price of one
[ __ ] dolls
just kidding there's no discounts john
mccain american here it's a great segue
john mccain now as you guys probably
heard recently passed I think we had
recently discussed John McCain for this
I what I consider and what I cherish as
one of the classiest moments in American
history recent American history because
as you know the country is so
politically divided it bothers me it
bothers most people frankly I mean
there's a lot of people that drink the
kool-aid on either side and it's really
cut like who watches CNN every day and
who watches Fox News every day that's
your team line okay now John McCain was
a conservative through and through he
was a fox news man and the people a lot
of people that that you know didn't like
Obama there was a lot of weird
conspiracy theories about him one of
which perpetrated by the way of our
current president which is probably the
dumbest I mean there's a lot of things
to say about Trump I'm not gonna get
into it but accusing obama of not being
an American citizen and it's probably
the dumbest and the most insidious
flat-out insane lie I've ever heard of
in my life yeah right so a lot of the
people bought into the Hat and one of
the women at the rally a lot of happened
several times actually a couple of times
where they say Obama is an Arab
obviously implying a lot more not
implying that Arabs can't be good people
but John McCain read between the lines
being you'll see for yourself but
basically this one the classiest moment
in my opinion in recent American history
where he went against the grain he
risked his own ass he's in you know a
town hall meeting with these people that
are thirsty a blood thirsty and he just
[ __ ] stopped them in his tracks he
said no and he knew he even gets booed
they [ __ ] turn on for actually
standing up for his values and and
speaking some some sanity
and the part that really pisses me off
well let me show you the clip but
actually now that this [ __ ] class act
and true American hero has passed on
you know the people on the Left who I
politically are supposed to be my
political allies because I am very left
I'm a very liberal person I say that all
the time
our eviscerating john mccain for this
clip the people that he's reaching out
to across the bridge yes how there's
because well let's watch the video yeah
i mean it's just so sad and it's so
[ __ ] sad let me play this frankly
worse we're scared we're scared of an
obama presidency first of all I want to
be President United States and obviously
I do not want senator Obama to be but I
have to tell you I have to tell you he
is a decent person and a person that you
do not have to be scared as a president
United States now I just hear them turn
on him I just now look I I if I didn't
think I wouldn't be one heck of a lot
better president I wouldn't be running
okay and that's the point that's you I
can hear the crowd turn on him
what are you dared to insinuate he's a
decent guy you don't have to be scared
of I mean how messed up is our country
that that simple insinuation he is not
the Antichrist you don't have to be
scared of him he he's a good person I
can't believe he said that you know yeah
the second part is the part that people
are outraged about I gotta ask you a
question I don't know why this lady was
[ __ ] right yeah look at her hair man
this lady's she's got FoxNews pumping
through her veins these fellas don't run
no really her these colors don't run at
all believing I can't trust Obama III
have read about him and he's not his
not he's a he's an Arab he is not no no
ma'am she's like no ma'am what do I say
what do something what to think
tell me what to think no he's a decent
family man citizen that I just happened
to have disagreements with on
fundamental issues and that's what this
campaign is all about he's not thank you
okay he's just saying stuff with this
like don't even go there we rise
arguments so nonsense exactly and so
here's the kind of tweet that I've been
seeing online I'm gonna show you one
example of many people many of supposed
enlightened people okay look at this
[ __ ] [ __ ] stop with the story
about how John McCain shut down a race
at a rally by saying Barack Obama wasn't
Arab but a decent family man a citizen
you can be Arab and an American citizen
you can be Arab and a decent family
person these are not opposed the story
perpetuate racism bro you perpetuate
racism you're perpetuating this great
divide and you are willfully I mean you
either didn't watch the same clip I did
yeah I mean dude that's not what he said
like he's read that what's what really
makes me sad is he's reaching out to
these people he's putting his ass on the
line to cross to make a bridge of glass
and dignity that doesn't seem to be
alive left honestly any more politics
and say you know what he was saying he's
a good man like if I'm gonna lose and
he's gonna be the president you guys
don't have to worry we disagree but
you'll have a good guy this this is so
sad to me it's great that people are
politicizing this trying to besmirch him
when when his intention and it's the
purpose of what he did was the exact
opposite of what they're trying to say
after his death yeah I mean she said
he's an Arab but her insinuation was so
much more that and he said what he's
saying is no he's not an Arab he's
saying no ma'am don't even I go yeah
no dude wherever it is that you're
trying to say yeah also he's going
off-the-cuff it's a live event he's
he's in the hole with all these people
ready to turn on him he's making a risk
they're like well actually we'll just
want to clarify that Arabs can be good
people he's not an Arab but Arabs can be
good people it's like dude he shut her
down I don't know I'm so I'm so sick of
[ __ ] people like this dude he could
look at this other tweet if someone
responds to him the same guy says I hope
you I hope you actually take to heart
the idea of reading tweets without your
own tweet from the hip assumptions
getting the way I clearly said the story
was racist this is the guy by the way I
don't but I'm just like man this it's
not even about him I've seen this
sentiment echoed you know a lot and I
just think it's it's a [ __ ] shame
like we should be honoring this like a
really courageous moment yeah nice of
him when I saw it
courageous and rest in peace to John
McCain the last honest vestige of class
and how can a guy like that even be
classy when the people he's trying to
reach out to our visser ating cuz it's
never enough mm-hmm that made me really
sad but I think John McCain's an awesome
dude and uh he said he said in his final
statement that he just wants to remember
that someone that served his country so
he definitely will be remembered as that
our EP and the words kill Tony from last
night alright let's move it on to this
footage I have to share with you guys is
one of the most intense and insane
things I've ever freakin seen in my life
you guys probably heard we covered a lot
of the fires last year that were
ravaging Ventura and Santa Barbara there
was a fire and NorCal or yeah I think
was in North Cal that was even bigger
than last year just have a gene and
destroying the state so on continues so
this father and son were out hiking and
it was all clear it was all good and
they saw smoke in the distance and
didn't think anything of it because it
was pretty far away but the winds picked
up and this fire started spreading super
fast and all of a sudden they're like we
got to get out we should we should get
out of here mm-hmm and so here is their
attempt to escape this forest they were
just on a hike and this veil is just I
mean it's one of the craziest things
I've ever seen it's a 70 year old dad
and a son and that Jeep escaping the
forest
go faster do I go
we can drive through this what so for
those of you they can't see they're
driving down a narrow forest path and
fires raging pretty much on all sides of
them really intense forest fire this is
trees falling over like a movie yeah it
doesn't feel real
so they got they think they're out the
fire is kind of cleared the dead said
we're out and then they turn a corner
and it's like the craziest hell escape I
can imagine just fire everywhere fires
raging over the road they're driving
through it literally driving through
fire
Jesus god help us
so so scary so they reached a log in the
road that was that was covering the road
it was on fire and it stops there which
is like the craziest cliffhanger of all
nine can't write it even in the movies
that clip much of it cliffhanger you
know what cinch
got I had know how the story ends I'm
gonna read it to you guys there okay
this shredder yeah there okay um I find
it interesting cuz that guy who's
driving is like 40 and the dad is 70 and
like in this life any situation how they
like devolve kind of back to like a
little child yeah so these [ __ ]
lunatics they kick it into reverse and
backed up through that whole road back
through there in Reverse and made it out
that's so crazy an excerpt of them
explaining what happened that's when
things went bad to worse a tree ravaged
by the intense fire had fallen down
across the road blocking their escape
route I saw that and I thought we were
going to die Justin said I thought we
were trapped there was no way we could
turn around on the road with his
father's guidance Justin kicked the car
into reverse and drove the vehicle all
the way back to the trailhead at the end
of the road at times Justin said he was
going as fast as forward two miles per
hour it was absolutely insane I don't
know how I was able to keep the car on
the road he said but somehow a few
prayers and higher power we stayed on
the road once they were back at the
trailhead which was safe from the fire
for the time being they walked down
towards a nearby cabin to see if anyone
could help them that's when they saw a
small boat floating on Lake McDonald
with two people aboard we flagged him
down and they came over and grabbed us
and we got onto the boat Justin said ten
minutes later we were on the water and
we saw the whole part of the lake shore
where we had been just standing just go
up in flames
crazy dude unbelievable
like I was just I was mind blown when I
wash I'm so happy that they I know I had
to when you first showed me the video I
was like you gotta tell me they made it
cuz I the thing is that you can't like
appreciate is how hot it must have been
yeah
and driving it like this road to drive
in Reverse and it's unbelievable
Jesus definitely took the wheel his
words anyway I just wanted to share that
little incredible thing I saw with you
guys
[Music]
we've got California lawmakers passed
bill to erase old park convictions the
state district DOJ what the [ __ ] is that
apartment of Justice Oh bless it out
please calm down sorry it's my fault
Department of Justice estimates that
almost two hundred and twenty thousand
cases are eligible for a ratio or
reduction they better pass that you
cannot make it legal and then be like Oh
everyone rotting in prison yeah
eat [ __ ] too bad imagine being in prison
for ten years for pot and then they make
it legal and they're like okay you can
come out now it's like [ __ ] anyone who's
in jail for president in this suppose a
land of freedom can you imagine like I
mean anyone could go to jail for having
marijuana it's like in your life like a
bright young mind getting wasted in
prison I [ __ ] our law our prison
system is the most I think barbaric
thing about this country almost really
by far and so man every one every one of
those 220 people should be handed a
joint two hundred twenty thousand two
hundred twenty thousand people should be
handed a fat blunt a hundred thousand
dollars I'm boxing my thing and I'll put
up a prize but they should all be
offered a fat blunt and a sincere
apology from the state of California
I mean that's that is just a goddamn
crying shame it's unbelievable I don't
think any I think that drugs should be
legal I think all drugs should be
illegal
personally I don't think what good does
it do society locking somebody with a
drug issue up in prison I'll tell it
what a good it does society it creates a
system of slavery a free labor hmm in
prison yeah and it makes a bunch of
people that I'll privately-owned prisons
a bunch of money so sick it's it
shouldn't be private that's that I know
something as that's prison yeah you want
to monetize locking people up it's
almost as sick as privatizing health
care almost oh man you're dying of
cancer well if you can't I mean the
treatments a million bucks do you have a
million bucks I guess you're just gonna
have to die then oh you're the richest
country of all time mmm I'll go to
prison they have a great health care you
just don't get paid you're basically a
slave but we will I wonder if you get
cancer treatment in prison probably
that's a good question I think you do I
think I think you do yeah I think you
get hooked up somehow the conditions in
prisoner I guess you have to make a free
a choice between freedom and dying of
cancer I love that and finally um Ethan
you're such a socialist [ __ ] you not a
so I'm a capitalist socialist okay let's
be realistic I'm not talking about
communism look at Scandinavia I love how
people always like socialism doesn't
work idiot how you gonna pay for it
let's go space force let's give rich
people a [ __ ] ten trillion dollar tax
cut how you gonna pay for help to
healthcare everyone else in the word
figured it out you sound like a social
if Israel can figure it out Israel where
they everyone anything they don't agree
about anything and they all care about
money and somehow they all figured it
out and you everyone has health care
it's pretty much free Scandinavia they
always say socialism work Scandinavia
Free University free health care utopia
everyone's happy great quality of life
they're not okay yeah it's a
capitalistic country I'm not talking
about communism you [ __ ] idiot be
realistic with what I'm saying just
don't want to go bankrupt over getting
sick you sound like a dirty socialist
take a scumbag now can i lock you up and
give you some cancer treatment in
exchange for your life
okay get a little political here for a
minute we just found out it's been one
year since our lawsuit ended and I can't
believe it's not been longer
I cannot believe kind of explains when I
look back that our lawsuit just ended
only one year ago explains how [ __ ] up
I've been mentally
we've moved twice in that time we were
in this gut-wrenching lawsuit your dad
has been sick this whole time
mm-hm and I've just been like it's such
a mental [ __ ] this whole time and like
you it's hard to look from the outside
but like damn it's been a crazy it's
been a crazy time it's been a crazy year
I've heard a lot of people say that
27:10 was their worst year mm-hmm seems
like on New Year's everyone's like this
is gonna be my year no it's not
guaranteed it's not anyway I thought
this was cute our attorney that did most
of the work on our case he sent me this
picture of his office he's got this
t-shirt hung on the wall of his office
the matter of law shirt that we made
that absolutely won and I was like man
that's cool as hell
it's a trophy as he put it yeah
and I thank you guys all for hanging
around it's been a tough year for us and
you guys hang in and round and caring
about what we're talking about what
we're going through sure means a lot to
us yeah
not been my best over this past year I
would say that I don't think so
I'm felt like it what is your best
anyway I felt like [ __ ]
you know I made a jacket that says I
feel like [ __ ] no no secret there a lot
of people related what do we do about
that well we all feel like [ __ ] what are
we gonna do about that hmm that was
great
Dan was that you maybe one last update
on the pool yeah I think we got a clear
winner with Joey salads at 44% 4,000
votes in Joey gone buddy so reach out to
them would you Dan will do okay let's
set this up I'm excited guys [ __ ] all
the banksters would wanna well we can
have like a tournament bracket so I get
a prankster tournament have old bracket
man I'll give a [ __ ] I kind of like the
idea of like untrained just get in there
and throw some punches I don't mean you
make no one is allowed to train yeah no
big deal we're doing calm shoenice is
the Guardian he's the boss she nice is
gonna eat a stick of deodorant before he
takes you on guys thank you for watching
this has been another correct opinion
zone h3 Tuesday episode I hope you're
enjoying these Tuesday episodes I have
no plan I'm stopping because a lot of
people don't know what to think about
things and if you need to know what to
think how to feel my friends it's
Tuesday we are fully enlightened and
when you're in the correct opinion is
owned you can
the wrong Friday is Tim Heidecker the
comedy legend I'm a pioneer God legend I
would say God I am both nervous and
excited to make his acquaintance because
as many of you know he is uh I have said
that he is the sole reason I've made
comedy yeah I think most of our
listeners know that so I think everyone
is probably feeling your dread
why can't I just be like why can't I
just be happily excited I feel like
that's normal to be like I'm gonna meet
one of my heroes
why do I have to
that's all your normal when your fire
you're actually excited about stuff and
like positively excited why do I have to
suffer it's a good thing why do I have
to suffer I shred it you jump at me is
like are we done yet yeah we're done
shut up
thank you everyone we'll see you on
Friday
I love yet go watch kill Tony we yeah
that was a lot of fun it's on YouTube
just type kill Tony world we did it I
was great let's go there may be great
show and you can do great
I didn't say a word that's hard stick I
was really nervous though what's the
[ __ ] so nervous again why do I have
to suffer I was excited to be there
I love their show I like them so why do
I have to suffer that's a question for
another time that's why we transcend we
think deeply this is not an experience
this is an Enlightenment we shall see
you on Friday on the h3 podcast and
might meant show thank you for watching
thanks for watching
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]